on prime crime we're talking about here
you want to
play like games i'm not playing with you
man
a frantic search that leads to gruesome
discoveries
she was nude except for tennis shoes on
her feet
when a body is burned the ultimate goal
is to destroy any sort of evidence
an unpredictable legal journey i think
it was
inappropriate and the supreme court made
the right decision that time
and the man at the center of it all
[Music]
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime prime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable
true crime cases when a teenager went
missing
no one at the time had any idea where
this disturbing case
would ultimately lead march
7 2009 cincinnati ohio
thirteen-year-old esme kenny decides to
go for an afternoon jog
but she never returns home when police
are called and start searching the
nearby woods
they make an unusual discovery
um
[Music]
anthony kirkland is found sitting
against a tree
he's apprehended and brought in for
police questioning
are you aware that there was a child
reported missing
did any officer talk to you about about
that
when they've broken down you you were in
this area right here right around the
time this curve
do you remember seeing a young a young
girl for example
[Music]
it's not only that kirkland was
suspiciously in the area of esme's
disappearance
but when police search him they find
knives
and esme's watch and ipod on him
what if i told you that this wristwatch
watching this radio
belong to this missing girl are you
serious
i'm asking you have you told me that i
haven't changed a lot of things
hell's up
kirkland though is adamant that he
doesn't know anything
this mother and father they're missing
their their baby girl
and then the suspect so the police
interview we know that took
several hours almost eight hours or so
which we know just generally speaking
that will
wear a person down but in this case it
worked to their benefit
eventually kirkland says he did in fact
run into kenny
or rather she ran into him
and it was an excellent thing
it was an accident she explained it to
me i'll understand it was
my template
okay and then what i'm trying to appear
she
[Music]
what did you do then
this is potentially a trauma response
for him
he had based on his confession
potentially a flashback
to the mother of his child
and the wrong doings that she
potentially had caused him
did you knock her out
where is she now where'd you move her to
do we need to find her right away or
is it too late
kirkland claims that he beat up the 13
year old and suggests
she's still alive but at one point in
the interview
detective keith witherell is called out
of the room and receives new information
from his colleague
when he comes back things change because
the officers
the officers located the little girl
they located her
in the woods and she's dead
the injuries to esme kenny's body
provide a story
of what happened the cause of death is
listed as
asphyxia due to ligature strangulation
her clothes were twisted and used as a
ligature
and you get more irregular marks around
the neck
and that's what we saw
did you kill her even how did she die
because of your anger
because
all right you punched her you kicked her
you stopped her
this is a child so this is a it's a
young child we're talking about here you
want to
play like games i'm not playing okay
with you man well you know what
she's defenseless you're you're you're
cat
mouse with me i killed her because of my
hatred well what does that mean
anthony something to know about
anthony kirkland he's not an ordinary
suspect
is there anybody else out there we need
to be looking for
more when we return
[Music]
back in 2009 13 year old esme kenny's
dead body is found in an ohio woods near
her home
suspect anthony kirkland who was located
in the area and had some of esme's
belongings on him
says he beat up the girl when she
accidentally knocked into him during a
jog
throughout his conversations with police
he says he didn't kill her
yet detectives are able to get him to
open up more
and more this child has a mother
and a father you are a father
they love their child like you love your
child
and i know you have a heart and i know
you have a soul
i call this forced empathy detectives
made this very
personal to kirkland by using his son
and it forced him to have empathy for
esme kenny's parents in that moment
and then eventually
what made you kill her
[Music]
there's a lot of people that get angry
there's a lot of people that have a
temper and they don't kill anyone
what i think was a bigger part of it was
his
misperception of commonplace occurrences
that he viewed as malicious
slights against him and that is what
escalated him and
sent him into this dissociative rage he
gave it
what does that mean he gave it to me
what did you do
that's not all in esme's case
she was nude except for tennis shoes on
her feet which are unusual
so that makes you think that something
sexual may have happened
[Music]
did you have sex with her after that
she told me i didn't believe
him so that when you choked her
given kirkland's involvement in the
death of this 13 year old girl
investigators wonder something is
kirkland tied
to other killings i have been
investigating the death of casana
crawford and mary jo newton
forty-five-year-old mary jo newton
seemed to be an acquaintance of
kirkland's
but as he explained it was a
relationship
that took a dark turn
[Music]
so she became a problem your friendship
was being challenged
and then uh didn't she
then what happened did she die in the
van
yes how did she die
what happened because of death
and she told me that that would probably
be a good thing
as for fourteen-year-old kasanya cherie
crawford
whose corpse was found in a wooded area
like kenny's
by all accounts kirkland just randomly
met
her near a high school
[Music]
[Music]
she
the way he chose his victims were pretty
interesting because it seems like at
least
on two occasions he almost just bumped
into the victims
um whereas there were other situations
where there was
maybe a relationship or at least
establishing some type of
friendship or commonality so it was
almost kind of random either he
he knew you and he snapped or he was
getting to know you and he snapped
his victimology is all over the place
a lot of serial killers will stalk and
target specific
people but his murders were a little bit
different because they were
a reaction to being wronged in some way
i think
kirkland would argue that he didn't
choose his victims
they chose him coming up
kirkland still has some more surprises
for law
[Music]
there more bodies is enforcement what
you're saying
[Music]
why did you try to have sex with this
girl and not the other ones
it was what she said she said
after 13 year old esme kenny goes
missing in ohio back in 2009
anthony kirkland tells investigators
that he not only sexually assaulted and
murdered her
but he killed two other people as well
in 2006
including another teenager kirkland
though
isn't done with his confession more
bodies
was she a working girls prostitute what
according to kirkland after trying to
pay kimya rolison for sex
he got into an argument with her that
turned deadly
i said she had a she had a plate
she had a knife so she had the knife you
just turn it on her because she came
after you
where did you hit her in the throat and
where did she wear out of the throat
from the jungle i told her the blood was
coming up
it was coming out too fast too quick and
she told me she cut
fellow legs i started
trying to get more but then i
i don't know i held her
while kirkland's victims were all
different and they died in various
circumstances
there was one constant one common mo
that would become synonymous with
anthony kirkland
each body had been burned when a body is
burned after they've died really it
seems as though the ultimate goal
is to destroy any sort of evidence so it
depends on how long the body has been
burning and really how thoroughly it has
been burned
in the first two cases where the bodies
were not discovered and they were
skeletonized and burned
you could not find any reason why they
died
i think there is a common misconception
that any sort of burning or charring of
the body will destroy
evidence the third case was also burned
but not enough that we couldn't see the
incised wound on the vertebrae
in our last case where esme was only
burned on her lower body and in her
groin region
there was not any direct evidence found
to indicate
who raped her but the evidence that
somebody had attempted
was still there what was the reason
my personal belief i thought that you
were trying to get rid of evidence
is so quiet
looking at how thoroughly the bodies
were burned and the fact that an
accelerant was used such as gas
it does seem that he was trying to hide
evidence
versus cremating the bodies for their
ultimate
burial anthony kirkland admitted to
killing four people from 2006
to 2009 and that's not even the most
shocking part
he actually killed before in 1987 he
strangled to death leola douglas
and set her body on fire as well after
serving
16 years in prison for manslaughter he
was released
in 2003 with five victims on his record
anthony kirkland is a bona fide serial
killer
up next kirkland goes to trial but it
doesn't play out
how you might think stay with us
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty
guilty think again judge caprio rules
with common sense
i was having contractions i was rushing
to the hospital respect to quinn what
does justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the long crime network is everywhere and
we invite you
inside the jury box this is law and
crime
[Music]
you killed a person last night
i can't control me
in 2010 ohio serial killer anthony
kirkland is on trial for the murders of
two women
mary jo newton and kimya rolison as well
as a fourteen-year-old casanya crawford
and 13 year old esme kenny kirkland
would plead guilty to murdering newton
and rolison
and the jury convicted him for the
killings of the teenagers
with kirkland receiving the death
penalty
he was convicted because the evidence
was pretty strong against him
he confessed to the crimes there's no
going back from that
however that's not even close to the end
of the story
while his convictions remained the ohio
supreme court held that kirkland was
entitled to
a new trial on the sentencing phase
because of comments prosecutor joe
deters made to the jury
specifically he suggested that if
kirkland wasn't sentenced to death for
the killing of the girls
then they would just be quote freebies
for kirkland
i know that prosecutors and defense
attorneys get emotional
they get attached to these cases and
oftentimes they'll say things that
may cross the line so as a judge it's
really hard to call
what's a good statement or a bad
statement but i think it was
inappropriate and the supreme court made
the right decision that time
now kirkland had a second shot at life
his resentencing trial began on july
25th
2018. is the mitigation outpoint by the
aggravation
period and if it's outweighed by the
aggravation and you're certain of it and
you're sure of it
you shall recommend the death penalty
for anthony kirkland
the defense focused on kirkland's mental
health and traumatic past
in support of a life sentence
you shall consider whether as a result
of a
mental disease or defect
the defendant was unable to control his
actions and conform to the law
the defense even called experts like dr
joseph wu who concluded kirkland had
brain abnormalities
which may have led to his actions he
testified that kirkland's brain scans
were similar to those
with chronic traumatic encephalopathy
for cte
cte is a brain injury that's associated
with violent and aggressive behavior
but an expert that was hired by the
prosecution said that the brain scans
looked
normal kirkland suffered abuse
as a child this is a guy that used drugs
growing up he was involved in a bicycle
accident so there may or may not be some
brain damage
there's potential for a head injury and
so
his ability to manage his impulses
is probably a little bit different from
most people
that filter's gone while jurors listened
to kirkland's confession tapes
they got to hear once more from the man
himself
i cannot offer an explanation for my
atrocious acts
i understand i have hurt so many people
with these horrible crimes
to all the families friends and loved
ones
of those hurt and still hurting from my
behaviors
i am truly sorry for your pain it's
difficult for me to tell if he's
remorseful or not
there's moments in his confessions and
based on his actions
it's difficult for me to see this
remorse
but the thing is is that when he comes
to terms with what he did
and was able to humanize his victims
he was able to show remorse the thing is
this is not a typical state of mind for
him
please understand though i am not here
to beg for mercy
nor your forgiveness i am proof a young
person
deeply abused physically emotionally and
mentally becomes the abuser
i do not blame you if you kill me i do
not deserve to live
but please spare my life now it was in
the hands of the jury
life in prison or death we therefore
unanimously
find that the sentence of death should
be imposed upon anthony kirkland
and signed by all 12 jurors including
the four person
they decided on death mainly because
there were victims who he didn't even
know
and who lost their lives and there's no
coming back from that
though he had trauma he was still
intelligent enough to make decisions
these murders were done in a calculated
manner he burned the bodies of the
victims
you know he hid the evidence so he
didn't lose his mind to the extent that
he didn't know what was going on
instead he lost his mind to the point
where he was making bad decisions
the judge ultimately imposed the death
sentence
kirkland appealed but the ohio supreme
court affirmed the judgment
two years later thereby seemingly
sealing his fate for good
anthony kirkland will go down as one of
ohio's most brutal killers
but it's the devastation he left behind
that has left
the greatest impact i think what sticks
at me the most
sticks with me the most is the potential
that was lost
with these victims and um
what someone like uh esme kinney could
have become
uh you know she could have she could
have been the most important person in
the world and yet we've lost her so
uh that's what sticks with me the the
uselessness of
something like this anthony kirkland
took
too much from this world this is a man
so evil that two different juries
recommended he be executed
at the time of this recording he's still
on death row
a harsh reality that despite his best
efforts
he just couldn't escape from and that's
all we have for you here on prime crime
leave us your comments on instagram and
twitter with the hashtag prime
crime as always thank you for joining us
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you